so you know the reason for the delay is
we um we there were there was some
paperwork glitch in the uh
in the paperwork that the clerk needs to
have for votes so we're we're waiting to
clear that up so we have the proper
names in the of the people on this
committee and then we'll be able to get
started
thank you for your patience
all right um I'm going to call the uh
executive session of the house Judiciary
Committee uh to order and I'd first uh
recognize representative G Lorenzo to
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
congratulations
thank you thank you representative
um
all right so
I think what we'll uh what will take up
uh first is the um
is the bill on which uh
where is it um
uh we we uh had a sort of ad hoc group
that that worked in more detail uh since
our last executive uh committee meeting
on Monday on HB 169 and so I recognize
uh representative cutoff please
I make a motion to itl 169.
is there a second
I seconded all right representative
seconded by representative Manos and uh
representative would you like to speak
to the motion
yes so this was a very difficult bill
for us we did meet
for a pretty good amount of time we we
all read through a pretty extensive
amount of cases
several of them which uh chairman you
had actually concurred on in your time
on the on the Supreme Court and
it just as much as as we feel for for
the family that we heard from we have a
concern that that this bill has the
potential to do more harm than good
because
it seems like it's ripe for Challenge
and
um it may not necessarily have even
helped in this case because we're not
defining kind of what that level of
evidence is and it is
somebody's judgment and everybody's
human and sometimes
the way that we decide things is
different than how somebody else would
decide and
um
we do plan to look further to see if
perhaps there's something that we could
enter for next year that may make more
sense
but unfortunately it just seemed as
though it due to the constitutional
right that the parents have and and the
fact that this is a consensual
Guardianship and that it wasn't ordered
on the basis of the parent being unfit
that unfortunately
requiring more than a preponderance of
evidence doesn't seem like it would
stand the test
so we again we did review everything and
we didn't take this decision lightly
and it's unfortunate but it seemed it
was best to itl the bill
any other comments uh yes representative
Perez
I think
fact that you're concerned about whether
it would stand up in the courts
personally do not feel that that's a
reason to itl this bill my biggest
concern with this is that
um the child is not being represented
and
if a child whether it's with agreement
or not with agreement there was a
problem with this family they were drug
addicts and they agreed to have the
child taken by the grandparent
if a child is put in
um it but and then they
they would give them back to the parents
and now they're in foster care I think
this happens more
then we realize it happens and my
concern about this is that the child is
not being represented and
being a having a drug abuse problem
is a is an illness and the illness
doesn't go away because
you're always a drug addict you're
always an alcoholic you always have the
potential I think that parents in order
it's hard to take parents away
it should be hard to allow a child back
into a home I just am very uncomfortable
with it I had thought about
um perhaps just having it studied longer
but I just it has to be more than it has
to be more than 51 percent that these
children go back I know of many many
many cases we just had two huge
public things here in New Hampshire that
went Nationwide Nationwide about
children that were lost in the system
who's speaking for the children here I'd
like to speak for the children I would
like to see if you lose your child
because of something abuse or
drug addiction or alcoholism or whatever
then you have to fight you have to prove
more than okay I went to rehab to get
that child back
thank you
yes representative kuta
I completely agree with much of what you
just said I think part of the concern
was that even if the judge had let's say
used a level of preponderance of
evidence and not given back a child to
the parents that this may give them
reason to challenge and say well
the law is clear and convincing and even
though you maybe only use preponderance
they're going to say your level of
evidence was too high and that's why you
didn't give the child back and so that's
where it has the potential to do more
harm in in that somebody who was
rightfully kept from getting their child
back may be able to appeal on the basis
of believing that the level of evidence
required had been too high
and that's where
it was really God In The Weeds
sure representative Perez and I
understand that and I I understand where
you're coming from but if you have to
work harder to get your child back
because
it's all based on
you know someone making that decision if
you have to work harder to get your
child back because it's not overwhelming
that you're due to then work harder
rather than have that child be given
back to you and then turn around and
have the child suffer these two national
cases that were here these children were
given back to parents two children dead
representative Manos
I was part of the smaller group and two
of the cases we looked at are Troxel
which is a U.S Supreme Court case and uh
Rina D which is a New Hampshire Supreme
Court case and I think they're
controlling precedence and I think
that's why we
um
made the recommendation that we look to
the Future to reconsider these issues
and that if we went beyond the amendment
that that was proposed we would be
um that it would be non-germaine and so
that was why we made the recommendation
to itl
all right anyone else want to speak on
on this side yes representative Andrews
thank you Mr chairman my thing is
on this
does
DHHS need to tighten their rules and
regulations and do a better job and
that's where the problem lies thank you
any other yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair uh the two court
cases Troxel and Rina d uh the dates of
them
are 2010 2011 something along those
lines and it appears that current RSA
has been modified since then and I've
not been able to determine what
modifications those exactly were but
perhaps because of the language of the
of the current law it appears like the
modification to have the grandparents in
a where the guardianship was by consent
and the and what we are looking at
potentially potentially modifying again
looks like the modification came after
those cases in response to the cases and
if that's true and I and I would I think
we should verify that but if that is
true then that's that's after and it has
sustained 10 years of of jurisp of
jurisprudence and so I I don't see how
Troxel and Rina D would then interfere
with the ability to modify it again and
so if someone I I think that
uh I have to agree I don't want to itl
this bill
um
because I think that that we if we can
at least find out if we can when these
modifications were made we can modify it
again
so so well yeah yes go ahead please
representative so we were able to follow
I was able to find the case that the
legislation actually came from it was
the case of Matthew P they recommend
they
that and you may remember this better
than me chairman it was recommended that
legislation legislator take a look at
this to make a change from the Matthew P
case and that's where this legislation
did come from
in my looking it seemed like the better
place to make the change had to do with
in the case of foster care there's a
12-month permanency hearing which then
the adoption goes into effect at the
24-month Mark that doesn't that hearing
doesn't happen in the case of a
consensual Guardianship and it seemed
that that was the place that the change
actually needed to take place
but unfortunately is is a non-germaine
Amendment which is why
we were kind of locked on what
we were limited with
Michelle yes so given the light that we
are I think we're all in agreement that
we would like to see if we could do
something could we retain this bill
instead of italing it right off the bat
so
can can I just uh uh if the question is
can't could we retain it yeah I mean we
could we could vote down the motion on
the floors to itl we could if that
motion failed then that we certainly
could entertain a motion to retain I
guess what I what I would say and I
would recognize representative Manos in
a moment
um there's
two two points that that I I think I I
would make and I hope you'll consider
the first is
the
the problem I think with the proposal
is is this as as the Troxel case points
out and as the arena D in other cases
and there's other cases from around the
country point this out
the parents have a fundamental right to
the upbringing you know to raise and up
and and uh bring up their their children
and the problem
that
of with with this proposed amendment is
this proposed amendment would say
even if the a court
were to conclude that the parents
had you know cleaned up their acts so to
speak so that they were now fit parents
even if the court were satisfied that it
was more probable than not that that was
true
the parents would still lose because
they hadn't satisfied this higher burden
of clear and convincing evidence and so
that what that really I mean if you stop
and think about that that means you're
you're a you're a fit parent you come
into the court and you prove now that
you're a fit parent whatever may have
been your your past track record you now
come in and you prove
that it's more likely than not that
you're a fit parent
and you and you lose anyway
that's I think where the Constitutional
problem would come in to say that you
can make it harder than that
um so I that's that's why I have a real
problem with the with the proposed
amendment even though I am sympathetic
to you know what people are saying the
other thing that I the other thing that
I would say and I hope you'll consider
this is
we the
the main evidence in support of this
bill comes from a a very compelling
witness I uh who appeared before us
but
gave us
her side of a court case
we never you know yesterday I was he I
was working here yesterday preparing
some amendments for some other things
and the child and family committee I was
in that office they were in years but I
could hear a fair amount of what was
going on
there were any number of bills presented
to change fundamentally in fundamental
ways the the the way the family court
operates
many many of those bills based upon
you know what somebody told somebody
about a court case
in which they got one side of the story
one side of the story and that's what we
got here we'd you know I please
understand I'm not saying for a moment
that judges don't make mistakes they do
and in fact it appears from what I
understand about this case of this that
in fact the the you know the child ended
up the parents ended up going back to
drug dealing and whatever or drug abuse
and the child was taken away again so
I'm I'm not you know that which would
that could indicate that that the court
made a made the wrong decision so I'm
not saying that courts never make
incorrect decisions but what I am saying
is I and I hope you'll just think about
this is
I think it's dangerous to legislate
based on a particular case and getting
one side of the story because I you know
I I I I can remember last year and I got
a particular legislator
um coming to me a number of times and
talking about you know this happened in
this case and we needed to change the
law we need to change the law
and I you know on several occasions
I I I I I thought to myself
I think I have a pretty good sense of
who the judges are in this state I don't
know them all or by any means but I
think I have a pretty good sense
generally about this and and I remember
saying to myself on a number of
occasions
even in the worst you know think about
the person that I think the least of as
a judge in the state and that was having
a bad day and maybe had a little too
much to drink the night before even in
that circumstance this judge would not
could not have made the decision that
was suggested on the facts that were
related to me it's just you know
incredible that that could have happened
which tells me
there must have been another side to the
story and of course we
you know we don't have that we haven't
read the transcript of this of this case
or those cases or anything so I guess I
just say I think it's kind of important
that to put that in perspective
representative work
just underlined what you said in your
comments were
um on the spot I I many many years ago
we very briefly a thing called the
petitions and redress committee which
was a failed experiment and that was
almost entirely
it's predominant almost entirely people
very civil cases have gone sideways I'm
usually defendants and family law cases
and uh of course they would usually
even if they brought documents that you
would usually only bring copies of their
own documents like the ones for their
case which is understandable and then it
was pretty easy
pretty easy to pull a file if the case
is gone to the Supreme Court it's a very
the clerk of Clerk of very like will
very in a few minutes bring you the case
File and you can sit out there and read
it just about every case I found that
there were like fairly severe
there's a fairly severe difference
between what we were told happened in
the case and what the case File actually
reflected so there's usually
there's usually a rationale for what the
other side of these cases were doing not
to say that necessarily all the
Commissioners were wrong or they're all
right but like
um there's one particularly amusing case
where he was always saying the judge was
doing things for no discernible or
rational reasons so you'd I finally got
hold of his case File which was like
particularly long I think he had like a
thousand items in the docket and uh
in every case there was a discernible or
rational reason for what the what the
court did you know so
so that's uh
so that is a problem with legislating
based on one party's uh possibly
one-sided and often very incomplete
summary of what happened in the court
case thanks representative
would it be possible for us to do some
sort of a A subcommittee or like little
study with a few of us to possibly
propose a bill for next year rather than
retain this one because I just don't
think this is the area that it would go
in I think it would be a whole new bill
is there any way that we could
do some little subgroup with us
I'm sure I mean the answer to that that
doesn't have to be something that's done
the answer is yes but that doesn't I
think that's not something that we sort
of have to act upon here yeah Yuka you
may you know you I mean I would
encourage anybody on this you know this
committee and if there's other you know
other committees that have an interest
in it maybe child and family or whatever
if if you think you have you know ideas
for for making the law better I I you
certainly should do that and I would
encourage it yes representative Perez
in my notes and correct me if I'm wrong
because again I apologize I'm going to
use the excuse It's new but I have in my
notes that I'm Brian Clark
testified and I have written down dcyf
wants to keep
clear and convincing
I think that might have been on the
first part yeah that was an in section B
and they have been neutral to the change
in section c but I should note that dcyf
doesn't have involvement with the
consensual guardianships typically and
so that's why they were neutral on it
because they have limited involvement
but the clear and convincing they were
just saying please don't make the change
in in Part B which is why I had made the
amendment
Mr here yes representative D Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair
um I think that we are looking at this
issue through a very narrow lens
um a parent a parents could lose custody
of their children due to no fault of
their own such as
um mental health a physical disability
so I think that when we do look at this
bill again we need to look at it with a
wider scope thank you
anyone else wish to come yes
representative Manos
I just wanted to suggest that one reason
not to retain it is because jurisdiction
might lie with children and family law
and so I agree with representative
koutab that um
looking at it further individually or as
a smaller group informally would be the
better course of action
anyone else wish to speak to uh
to this bill all right so the motion on
the floor is
to itl HB 169 are we ready for the
question
all right so I'm going to ask the clerk
if you would please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes
rep Stapleton is absent
rep trip YES Prep Grayson yes
clerk yes Brett Perez
yes
rep Smith yes
reporter again yes rep dilorenzo yes
the rep that's subbing for Kenny I'm so
sorry
rep Eaton
is that a yes
rep page
Brett Brennan yes
rep divine
yes rep blanza yes rep Manos yes repter
yes
chairman Lynn yes
19 years
so that
the uh
itl passes and it uh anybody reason to
any reason that that could not go on
consent
all right it will go on consent
and let me turn to uh
next
um
tomorrow
uh House Bill uh 320
um FN and the uh relative to free speech
and interactive computer services and
the chair recognizes representative
greeson for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move that uh House
Bill 320 be found in expedient to
legislate all right is there a second
I second that all right second uh
representative reason would you like to
speak to uh the motion yes sir thank you
uh House Bill 320
is attempting to
prevent social media platforms from
censoring content posted by users and
that is we have
we have seen over the last few years
where this has occurred and in great
graded amounts
federal law
distinguishes between
platforms and Publishers this is section
230 of the federal code
a platform is one in which the social
media
company allows users to post the
comments and such that that the users
want to post on there and within a
reasonable amount of content regulation
uh these the social media platform is
able to they allow them to you post
whatever those things are and without
liability for those comments
in contrast to a publisher where the uh
the social media company would then be
actually controlling what is posted what
is not posted and so when censorship
takes place
uh they become a a publisher and not a
platform and should therefore not be uh
should not be protected by by the
liability protections that they're
granted so while this bill
seeks to uh to accomplish the the
purpose of preventing censorship I don't
see how we can actually enforce this
uh it would be very very difficult at
best to do that however I think even in
italing the bill
we can send a very strong statement to
these social media platforms that
platforms is reminding them that they
are platforms and not Publishers and
that censorship is not it should not be
tolerated
right other people wish to yes
representative Horrigan please well I'm
I'm certainly a very huge free speech
and freedom of the press uh
advocate of well first of all of course
it's not Freedom press includes the
um option to not print things you don't
want to print so like you know it's if I
post something on a Twitter or Facebook
it's not my press it's their press and
they have to do
a certain amount of content moderation
you can call it censorship uh first of
all there's a lot of stuff that
that people
some people want to post which nobody
wants to see you know nobody wants to
see uh work from home scams or just you
know incoherent Nazi rants or uh you
know or that sort of area there's all
kinds of things that you're gonna people
gonna try to post on any platform which
will just clutter up the platform and
also even
so and also even in terms of political
debate and maybe that's kind of in a
fortunate things in some ways but
they're
they're in the business of uh you know
they're basically in the business
they're providing these services for uh
for free in exchange for us being
exposed to some some advertising now and
then and um people aren't going to log
on to the service unless it's stuff that
they
enjoy reading not necessarily just stuff
that they agree with you know it
wouldn't be fun to see a social media
site where everybody agreed with me but
it has to be
you know it has to be
if it's not like within the if it's not
within certain parameters and I'm
willing to look at uh you know I'm not
going to log on the site nobody else is
going to log on to the uh the site so we
some extent we have to respect their
business model unless the market will
correct it uh
correct it somewhat you know sites that
aren't interesting to read sites that
are offensive to read people will
migrate away from them and go to other
sites and then they also come and go
anyway over the course of time just
because of natural Revolution like you
know one time
AOL and CompuServe dominated the social
media space and you know now they
ol will kind of exists but you know
compenserve doesn't exist and I'm sure
the uh
same will happen eventually to Facebook
and Twitter and the like so new new
platforms do come and go so I I um their
Monopoly power is not
I mean it can be troubling uh sometimes
but um especially especially in the case
of Twitter we had an eccentric
billionaire bought it and I really don't
exactly understand what he's up to half
the time but
I think uh so I think the concern buying
this pill is is exaggerated the
marketplace will correct it eventually
and also um
also of course this is a federal issue
so we have very limited uh purview over
this so the only thing
this might accomplish would be for
social media services to start redlining
users a Believer from New Hampshire and
that would certainly not be good
especially if you want to keep our first
the nation primary so I would
I would agree for slightly different
reasons that we said itl this bill and
thanks
yes representative Turner yeah just one
other point that I think is worth making
sure we draw out is uh during during the
testimony in section 359 u4
um it basically came out that that
anyone essentially who has any
interaction with anyone in social media
that touches New Hampshire would have
potential standing for this which could
open up New Hampshire as as the the
grounds where all cases of social media
because this doesn't Exist Elsewhere
um would be viably heard no matter where
you lived in the world and related was
the question of needing these social
media platforms to then collect
information about where you physically
were at a given time in both of those I
think are really uh uh difficult issues
to overcome
anyone else
so I guess I'm I have to say that I'm
I'm going to vote for this motion and
I'm uh I I support it I but I I am torn
about the about this because I do I I do
think it's really unfortunate that
there's been
um that that
the social media platforms have chosen
to build to sort of behave
um in the for lack of a better term sort
of woke manner that many of them have
um but
I'm concerned that the that the medicine
may be the Cure may be worse than the
disease and in particular
I'm I'm really worried about what the
implications would be about holding some
of you know Google or Twitter or the
Facebook whatever to be Public Utilities
I'm not quite sure that the analogy
between that and you know eversource uh
or at T holds and I'm I'm concerned that
there would be other implications
um that uh
frankly those of us who believe in kind
of limited government and let the free
market do its thing would not be happy
with
um so that on balance
um that's why I come out to support the
itl and I have to note as as I think a
couple of people have pointed out but
you know I just just to give you an
example
this bill proposes to uh for Protect
free speech
um uh on the on these platforms but then
if you if you look at section uh u43 and
I'm quoting here this chapter does not
prohibit an interactive Computer Service
social media platform from merely
providing expression to a user in a
particular instance in response to that
user's Express request in that
particular instance for expression
limited on the basis of viewpoint or
geographic location I'm not
I'm not quite sure I know what that
means but it would seem to me that that
would allow you could drive a lot of
Mack Trucks through that uh through that
exception and uh which I think kind of
shows that there's that this is
problematic so anyway
um enough on that but that's why I'm
gonna I'm gonna vote in favor of the itl
motion
anyone else have anything uh
to say all right are you ready for the
question
all right then uh the motion before uh
uh
the body is uh itl on uh HB 320
um and I would ask the clerk to please
call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep trip yes rep Grayson
yes
clerk who tab yes
rep Perez
rep Smith yes
rep Horgan yes rep dilorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes
rep page
rep Brennan yes rep divine
yes rep Lanza
yes rep Manos yes rep Terror yes
motion passes night oh chairman Lynn
sorry that's all right uh yes
motion passes 19 to zero all right and
any reason
um that that cannot go on consent none
all right
um
next uh return to uh HB uh 171 FN and
the chair recognizes representative
Alexander for a motion thank you Mr
chair I move HP 171 in expedient to
legislative I'm going to second that
motion uh is there at representative
representative Alexander would you like
to speak to that yes thank you Mr chair
um the bill would change definition by
adding a requirement
um employee I'm reading from the fiscal
note employer officials decisions
um or a mission to be discretionary
rather than ministerial
um this opens up more lawsuits for
ministerial functions which expand
liability for
um our state and local governments um I
see no reason to expand a liability
right at this time I think the bill is
formatted
um
formatted also incorrect like not in a
good way so I just hope that the
committee would join me in
itl in this bill I think
um
there are other bills that the committee
will look at as well that
um
have to do with the same subject area so
with that I hope you join me in ideal
all right anyone else wish to speak to
HB 171
all right are we ready for the question
then uh on House Bill 171 on the motion
of inner speaking to legislate I would
ask the clerk to put please call the
rule
foreign
Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews yes rep testerman yes
reptrip
rep Grayson yes
clerk kutab yes Brett Perez yes
rep Smith yes rep hoorigan
rep Delorenzo
yes
rep Eaton yes
prep page
rep Brennan yes rep devang yes rep Lanza
yes rep Manos yes Rapture yes chairman
Lynn yes
motion passes 19 to zero all right and
again it's any reason that that cannot
go on consent
seeing none we'll put it on consent
um
next uh we turn to HB 314 FN
um relative to the expectation of
privacy in the collection and use of
personal information
and I'm going to recommend I'm going to
recognize myself and uh with a motion to
retain
is there a second I'll second atmosphere
all right motion's been made in second
and let me um explain
um the basis of this motion
um
I think this is really an important bill
and I I really want to recognize
representative erf uh for his work on
this he's done a lot of work on it
um and I I I've tried to work I work
with him on on this and
um I had proposed which I think you've
seen I've proposed an amendment which I
know he and I disagreed on
um I thought it was necessary to sort of
to
um
restrict the potential reach of the bill
but after discussions with him and after
discussions with the former uh
representative uh
Kirk from sorry thank you former
representative Kirk from where
I think that there are I I hope that we
will be able to move forward with this
legislation and hopefully in a
bipartisan way
um next uh session but I think there are
issues
that need to be resolved and it needs to
be
tightened up uh more than more than uh
it is right now for I mean for example
one of the
one of the big
issues that um that representative erf
and I talked about and I think we may
have talked about a little may have been
raised a little bit at the hearing is
it's
one thing
um to to restrict
the government's ability to
get and maybe release to other people
private information
it's another thing if you're talking
about
private
to Res to create a uh right of privacy
in our information when it's in the
hands of a third party that's not the
government
um and what the potential implications
of that could be uh to Industry I mean
we heard some people testify about their
real concerns about what the
implications of that would be for
industry but let me let me just draw it
I think that's what this there was
reference made to this at the hearing I
believe let me just draw this this uh
this analogy or not maybe which may not
be great but I think it makes the point
the in New Hampshire the New Hampshire
Supreme Court has held that there's an
expectation of privacy in your trash so
if you you know fill up your trash bag
you put it out at the curb
um the government the police cannot just
go and open up you know go up go
sniffing through your trash bag and say
ah look what we found here you know I
there's uh something this is my drug
proceeds Ledger or whatever they they
can't do that they got to get a warrant
if they want to do but
that doesn't mean that if you're the
neighbor of the person or you're you
know uh
a homeless person that happens to be
walking by down the street that you
can't open up that bag and if you did
that you that you could be held liable
there's no law that I'm aware of that
would say that you know that if if that
happened your neighbor comes in and
opens up the uh opens up something that
you've put out in the trash that you can
sue your neighbor and and collect
um and get an injunction or collect
damage or something like that I mean
that certainly that if that were if if
you could do that it certainly wouldn't
be based on any kind of constitutional
provision uh and so I think we I think I
guess what I'm really saying is we need
to think really carefully about this I
hope we'll have more time to do that
um over the over the summer and and be
able to come back with uh with uh
with a bill that will be
Tighter and will be able to to draw
bipartisan support because I think that
that
an interesting I mean I think we all
have an interest in protecting privacy
um so that's all I have to say
representative Smith
thank you very much
um Mr chairman um
I don't think we all have an interest in
protecting privacy so I'm sorry to
disagree with you on that I have an
interest in protecting privacy and I
think many others do because we are
going to retain this spill I don't feel
the need to go through all my reasons
why I think this is a very important
bill I think we are a state that has had
a long tradition of being libertarian in
terms of keeping the government out of
private
private business and I feel very
strongly about that I strongly I support
your recommendation of retain and hope
we will have some detailed conversations
about this in the next few months so
that we can end up with a strong bill
that could pass the house overwhelmingly
thank you
anyone else wish to yes representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair and and I
would like to Echo my friend from Durham
I think she's entirely correct uh we
worked um last term on
um a bill in a work session I'd like to
continue that tradition to try to make
this the best Bill possible
um my concerns with this bill as is
um is
an individual shall have a reasonable
expectation of privacy and personal
information I see that as private
entities made the argument that
um there was no distinction between
private and public even though later in
the bill it did concede that it's only
public information in 507 H3 line 26 27
page two and the other concern I have is
when a public entity shares private
information there's no standard of
negligence and I'd like to see that
negligent standard in the bill in some
way so with that I absolutely would like
to retain this and I'm happy to spend
the summer months with um representative
Smith and hopefully work on this thanks
anyone else wish to speak
that's a very good point representative
Alexander the the standard the
culpability standard they're they're I
think that's that's something that was
missing and and I'm glad you pointed
that out all right um so we're ready for
a vote all right so on uh HB 314 FN uh
the the motion on the floor is to retain
and I'd ask the clerk to call the roll
please
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes reptrip yeah
rep Grayson
yes
rep Perez yes
rep Smith yes
prep poor again yes
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton yeah
rep page
Brett Brennan yes rep Divine yes rep
Lanza yes rep Manos yes reptario yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 19 to zero
and so I you know I should say I um one
thing I I I learned yesterday that I
didn't I didn't realize is when we
retain a bill it doesn't go on the
calendar
um because it's it's state what it means
is it stays in committee so we'll have
it
um we'll have to uh we'll have a meeting
in the fall we'll have to decide you
know what we want to what
recommendations we might make for
legislation for next term but it doesn't
go on the calendar for when it's a
retained
um
all right
um and I I didn't know that until uh
until yesterday
um I'm going to turn to HB 149 FN
relative I'm sorry yeah no no
I'd like to make a motion on this oh uh
okay hang on one second relative to
handling of requests made under the
right so no law and I would recognize
first representative Alexander for a
motion thank you Mr chair I moved to
retain HP 149.
is there a second
I'll second it right would you like to
speak to that uh representative
Alexander yes obviously uh uh have
representative Smith speak yes Mr chair
and and I I don't want to speak for
representative Smith I think I I
wholeheartedly support this bill I think
it's a great bill I think it's important
that we put reasonable timelines on
government entities for right to no
requests I think this is a completely
reasonable Bill and a reasonable
timeline
the concern I have is that we just
recently this committee supported a
right to no one budsman who took office
I believe this week or last week we
haven't seen the rulings of the
Ombudsman I think it's a very valuable
position much needed but I think that a
lot of the things in this bill
can be solved by the Ombudsman so I
think the thing that we should think
about is time and give the Ombudsman
time and if the Ombudsman hasn't
addressed it by the time we deal with
this in November I would be willing to
sit down with representative Smith and
hopefully we can amend our past bill as
is thanks
representative Smith
thank you very much Mr uh chair
um I I apologize for trying to make the
motion but since it was my bill I
thought that
I might get the first stab at it uh
nonetheless you're the chair and I
support what you did
and as you all know I have great regard
for my colleague from Goffstown
um but with all due regard and respect
and all those positive words there is
nothing in this bill
that is immediately relevant to the
Ombudsman in fact a co-sponsor on this
bill is the person who played the
greatest role in this legislature in
getting in Ombudsman and still felt that
this bill was necessary and that of
course is our colleague from Newmarket
we have seen again and again and again
and we have seen no indication
um of changing the minds of those people
who are resistant to the concept of
right to know
uh we have seen no change in their
attitude that they can take as long as
they would like and prolong as long as
they would like their response all this
bill says is okay if you want to take a
long time to respond
fine but you must tell
um
uh
you must tell the complainant that's not
quite the right word what's my right
word right
how long it's going to be and if every
30 days you have to say well yes this is
the this is the progress I've made or we
haven't made any progress and this is
why you can go on and on and on and on
but at least you have a responsibility
to the public to tell the public why you
haven't yet complied with the laws of of
right to know and so I think that we can
delay this
we can retain it but that means all
those people who have filed right to
know requests and are not getting
responses from some public agencies
there are many public agencies that do
the right thing but there's some that
don't
and um meanwhile they're not going to
get help and I would hope the committee
um in due course would vote down retain
and would entertain
um and not to pass motion thank you all
right yes representative greeson thank
you Mr chair uh I think everybody's in
agreement that we need to address the
issue of government entities not
providing the records that are requested
and doing it in a timely manner one of
the issues I found in this particular
bill is that there's no actual
requirement to provide any records you
can delay it 30 days you can delay it 30
days you could delay it 30 days as long
as I tell you I'm going to delay it 30
days I get 30 more days and so uh I I
would actually like to see this bill
modified to say not to exceed 90 days or
some some deadline and then if you can't
meet that then there's some other course
of action either take it to the judge or
take it to the Ombudsman whatever the
case may be but the fact that there's no
actual requirement to produce the
records or there's no set deadline by
which the records are are actually going
to be provided I see that there being an
issue with the current bill in its
current state
other anyone else that wishes to uh yes
representative Andrews thank you Mr
chair
I think the bill needs a little more
work on it there has to be a time frame
in the last nine years I have dealt with
my school district asking for
information off and on and unless a
person asks
for something extensive that's really
going to take a lot of research there's
no reason
to keep going well I can't have it in 30
days and in the end of 30 days well I
got to have another 30 days because I
think as a disservice to the public and
I would in this bill I would really love
to see some kind of reasonable time
frame thank you
anyone yes representative tur
yeah just coming at it from a different
perspective but
um I think a reason to move it forward
as it is
um is almost the opposite of sort of the
issues of of stonewalling by local
municipalities I think the idea of
reporting on the progress and Reporting
on the work that's going on in order to
fill some of these requests and I'm
picking up on what representative
Stapleton said during the hearing you
know that there is also you know people
who put in very broad right to know
requests that require a lot of time and
legal review
um in order to fulfill and I feel like
this might help elicit or or shine a
light on the amount of effort that does
go into some of these so that's why I
would support it
anyone else wish to be heard regarding
HB 149 all right so the motion on the
floor is a motion to retain are we ready
for the question
yeah can I ask the clerk then to call
the roll please
base chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews
rep testerman yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson
yes
clerk who tab yes rep Perez yes
rep Smith
rep Corrigan yes
rep Delorenzo no
rep Eaton
rep page
rep Brennan
no
rep Divine no
rep blanza no
rep Manos no
repturer no
chairman Lynn yes
ten to nine motion passes
all right um
check
all right
um right
so I'm going to uh
I'm gonna turn I'm gonna I'm gonna pass
on Passover 289 for the mo I have 254 at
the moment and turn to uh House Bill 289
uh relative to consultation with legal
counsel under the right to know off and
I'm going to recognize uh myself
uh uh and move uh itl on that bill and
ask if there's a second there is
motion has been made and seconded um and
give me just one second while I turn to
the bill
so I basically my my
reason for uh wanting to itl this bill
is I just think it is really completely
unnecessary
um what pardon
29 that's always it on 289 289.
yeah no that's all right no problem so
the reason I um I believe that that uh
itl in this bill uh is appropriate is
that I just don't think this bill is
necessary
um it suggests that
um we should have a we should add a
Proviso to the provision that allows
um uh
I I
um
there to be a a non-public session
um to consult with Council
um it goes on to say to provide under no
circumstances shall a member of a public
body retain or consult with Council for
the purpose of evading compliance with
this chapter and then creates a criminal
penalty it
I it it just seems to me that this is is
a solution in search of a problem
um if an if if an if an attorney were to
do that now
um they the attorney would be subject to
uh I mean assuming it could be proved
and of course that would be the the
proving that that somehow a consultation
with Council was not really for a
legitimate purpose would be
um I think would be something of a
Fool's errand but but even it but if but
if that could could happen then the
lawyer and the lawyer Were Somehow to
participate in that I think the lawyer
would already be subject to disciplinary
action by the bar
um and and there would be the there
would be no
there were the uh the public officials
who did this for a
non-uh proper purpose would be subject
to having the the uh right to know law
their their decision reversed by the
court uh under the right to know law as
it is now so I just think that this
adding this language doesn't really do
anything
um and and that's basically the reason
for my Ito
representative org well I think
I also would go further and this bill
appears to be totally
unconstitutional since everybody has
everybody has the right to counsel um
even a public official who's suspected
of trying to evade right to no law in
any case the council's
role would properly just be to
advice advise them how to uh how to
comply with the law even though of
course there's a lot of nuances on
what's complying with the long what
isn't complying with the law but yeah
you wouldn't be able to approve the
council wasn't merely trying to advise
his or her client on how to stay within
the boundaries of the law even if
they're going very close to the boundary
of the law so this
any other comments on this bill
all right are we ready for a vote then
uh on uh
uh HB 289 FN the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate and I would ask
the clerk to please call the rule
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes clerk who tab yes rep Perez
yes
rep Smith yes
rep Corrigan yes
rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton yes
rep page yes rep Brennan yes rep divine
oh you weren't here sorry when they
called okay rep Lonzo yes
rep Manos
yes
repturer yes
um eighteen to zero oh sorry chairman
Lynn sorry yes that's all right
so 19 to zero sorry okay
no it's 19 because stapleton's here now
yeah
um
all right and uh is there any reason
that this cannot go on consent anybody
anybody object to going on consent all
right so we can go on consent
um
next I'm going to turn to
um HB
relative to attorney seizing actions
under the right to no law and I would
recognize representative Perez for a
motion
yes I would like to make a motion to
have this be ought to pass
um is there uh I wanna we wanna hear
from you but let me first ask you if
there is a second a second the motion
all right all right representative Perez
fortunately for me this is a very simple
bill
basically going back to giving people
the right to
if a judgment is made in their favor the
right to have their attorney fees return
to them so it's
it's appears to me to be very reasonable
and
it's not until a final judgment is
rendered so therefore I'm in favor of
ought to pass right anyone else wish to
speak to this bill
um I I I'm just going to make a brief on
it I'm I think we're
pretty much I think pretty much everyone
agrees to this and I I do think it's uh
an appropriate change I'm particularly I
think uh uh attorney Bissonnet from the
ACLU who testified on the bill
I mean I think I think his point was was
very well taken that one of the one of
the things that this bill will
accomplish is it that it will it will
sort of signal to public bodies that the
default position the presumptive
position ought to be that materials are
are to be disclosed now sure there are
reasons for not disclosing it in
particular uh cases as specified in the
statute but that
ought not to be the presumption that
local officials or state officials start
out with I think he made a very good
point on that and I think this this will
will help to change the mindset it seems
to me
um and so and I and plus I'm just on the
marriage I think it's a fair it's a fair
change so I strongly support
ought to pass
anybody else wish to comment all right
are we ready for a vote then um on HB
307 FN the motion on the floor is ought
to pass and I would ask the clerk to
call the roll please
chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep chip
yes rep Grayson yes clerk kutab yes rep
Perez yes rep Smith
reporgan
yes rep dilorenzo yes rep Eaton yes YES
Prep page yes rep Brennan yes rep Divine
yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes repterra
yes chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20-0
and is there uh oh this is not a
physical note so we can't get more of
this it isn't it is indeterminate
well I I I I think we probably should
not try and put this on consent because
I think I'm going to get pushbacks from
the clerk so we'll put this on the
regular uh calendar
um
all right
next I would like to turn to
um
HB 321
uh FN uh hang on a second
find it
all right
321 FN relative to minutes from
non-public sessions under the right to
no law and I recognize representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair I move um
HB 321 on to pass
second right
representative Alexander you wish to
speak to uh
your motion yes um this is a great Bill
Mr chair so I'll um last year we passed
a bill that would require municipalities
keep a list of minutes that are
non-public in the date that those
minutes were sealed so all this bill
would do would
um require that the public body review
those minutes every 10 years and make a
vote to determine whether those minutes
should be unsealed or not
um because there's a date already on the
list it's a very simple bill that would
actually New Hampshire Municipal
Association said it would have a
negligible if any fiscal impact on
municipalities
um and I actually want to point out that
this is um it's really great to hear in
judiciary when right to know New
Hampshire and New Hampshire Municipal
Association support and strongly support
the same bill so
um I would hope hope that my colleagues
in a bipartisan way will pass this bill
thanks
anyone else wish to speak on this bill
all right are we ready for a vote all
right then on S uh on HB 321 FN
um the motion on the floor is ought to
pass and I would ask the clerk to please
call the roll
base chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep Grayson
yes
clerk who tab yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Eaton yes
Brett page
rep Brennan yes
rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos
yes
reptario yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20-0
um
and again I see that there's a there's a
FN on this
um
say here uh it's indeter minimal and in
testimony it was minimal I think it's
under like five thousand dollars Mr
chair or something like that you don't
have to put it on consensus issue
all right so we'll try we'll put it on
consent and uh see if I get yelled at
all right either anybody should say
anybody object to putting it on consent
no either way Finance has to look at it
anyways
for some reason I think
but I think we might be able to do that
with 307 it says indeterminate all right
so you know what let me just ask that's
a good point let me just say is any
would anybody if we could do it and we
will make inquiry would anybody have a
problem in putting 307 on consent if we
can if we can do it
anybody have a problem with that all
right we'll we'll inquire and if we can
we'll do it I'm going to put it on a
consent we'll hear about it later
ask for forgiveness instead of
permission all right
all right
um
347 okay yeah I'm gonna turn next to uh
HB 347.
um
establishing a superior court uh land
use docket and
um
I am going to recognize myself
uh to make a mo I I have an amendment
um Amendment the amendment is
um
2023-117 h
and I would uh
moves the amendment and
um is there a second
Mr chair I can second or representative
Smith if you'd like to
would you like to second that or do you
want to
be happy
so if I may speak to the motion um
this bill would establish a
Superior Court
land use docket
the amendment in particular let me just
address that during the hearing you may
recall
representative uh Smith raised a a
couple of questions uh very good points
that um we needed that the way the
original bill was drafted it said that
there would be the governor would
appoint the first Justice of the of the
Superior Court land you socket didn't
specifically say it had to be a new an
additional judge so to speak so
presumably if there were a vacancy on
the Superior Court under the original
Bill the governor could have just filled
that vacancy with
um with a
uh
with an existing position this bill
changes that language to make it clear
that it's uh that it's an additional
Justice of the superior court and in
section two of the bill it specifically
uh indicates that this that the
um the uh Staffing of the Superior Court
shall be increased from a chief justice
and 21 justices to his chief justice and
22 associate Justice the other point
that um
uh representative Smith uh uh discussed
with me and I've made it made sense to
me I didn't have any problem with it was
to add language on page to line one
you'll see it at language has been added
that says nothing in this section shall
affect the concurrent jurisdiction of
the housing appeals board to hear
appeals within the jurisdiction uh
within its jurisdiction brought pursuant
to RSA 679 so
what I I think that even if that
language had not been included the
result would be the same because nothing
in this bill would propose to you know
Outlaw or or change the land use uh
other housing appeals board but
um it it doesn't hurt to have that in
there and I therefore had no objection
to when when representative Smith raised
that to including
um this in the language so I think
um the amendment uh makes sense and I
think for the reasons that I stated at
the hearing that it does make sense to
have a superior court land use stock it
I I have to say
that um
I have heard an argument not from anyone
on this committee but
um from
I've heard an argument from some people
saying No this is a bad idea
to have
um to have
um you'll notice it in the bill it says
that you know the first judge of this of
the land you stalk it has to be somebody
who's uh uh
has experience in land use law and that
kind of thing they think somebody you
know said to me that's a bad idea so I
can't help thinking you know just
thinking to myself and I said to them so
it's the idea that you would rather have
somebody deciding land use cases who
knows nothing about land use law or I
mean that is that a better is that a
better way to go I I don't think so
these are as I think you've heard at the
um at the hearing the these are these
candy pretty complicated cases and it
does seem to me that it makes sense to
have uh someone who has expertise in
that area and I would again I would note
by analogy
uh to the business uh the Superior Court
business court docket that's been in
effect now for over 10 years probably 15
years
um it's really been the first Justice
appointed for that was Justice McNamara
had a great deal of familiarity in
business law matters
um and uh from everything that I've
heard
um he served he served until he written
to you reached the mandatory retirement
age and really did a I think you know if
you check with among any members of the
bar I would say he really did a very
excellent job uh in that and it was that
it that was and now and judge Anderson
has taken over that docket
um it was and is uh success and I think
the land use stock it was uh would would
turn out to be the same way so for that
reason I hope you will uh support the
amendment and then support voting on the
bill as amended
yeah so first we anybody anyone want to
yes representative Perez I just have a
quick question this does not prohibit
them from taking a Justice who is there
already moving them to this where they
have experience and then bringing
someone else in or does it no I don't
think it does in other words they just
have to be it has this has to give a new
a new Justice and the person and the
person who was chosen even if it was a
an existing Justice would have to be
someone who fits the definition of you
know having experience in that area
other
any other questions so I think this is
on the amendment I think we can vote uh
by by a Voice vote unless anybody wants
to have it be a show of hands or a roll
call
seeing none
um I uh call the question all those in
favor of amendment
117 H to house bill 347. please say aye
aye any opposed
by hearing nothing all right we then now
move to the main bill of of uh
the uh ought to pass on uh HB 347 as
amended
um any further discussion on that
yes representative Andrus thank you Mr
chairman uh what I have to say uh Bob
Lynn I told him the other day I was
going to vote against this bill and I
have not changed my mind
in 2022 we had another bill House Bill
excuse me 1389
it was went to interim study they had an
interim Study last November we voted in
judiciary not to go further with the
bill and what was written on it is the
following
uh not recommended for future
legislation
this bill provided for the establishment
of a judge to decide land use cases
within the existing structure of New
Hampshire's superiors Court while the
idea of creating a specialized Co-op to
hear cases arising from Municipal land
use board decisions has some Merit the
majority of the committee considered the
present status of the New Hampshire
judicial branches caseload and the lack
of the full complement of 21 Superior
Court judges sitting on the bench and
determined that this initiative is not
presently appropriate in addition it was
suggested that targeted judicial
training in the state's coal land use
principle May adequately address the
concern which gave the rise to this bill
the vote was fourteen to five my thing
is this for years the legislature has
made laws and told the towns
within reason why you can do what you
can't do for your zoning and and they
could make up their own policies etc etc
if all that was good for years what is a
problem now I really don't understand as
far as I'm concerned we are taking the
rights away from our local people
if they are making bad decisions which
anybody can
then they should receive appropriate
training so these bad decisions don't
continue
we also have the house appeals board you
can currently take a case to Superior
Court I think personally we are just
adding another layer why are we singling
out
land use when in Syria Superior Court I
believe there's a lot of other
particular cases that maybe we should
hire one judge and they take over those
cases again I'm going to vote no on this
Bill thank you
other yes representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair I I think this bill is a
great bill
um it sets up a separate land use docket
that a judge with that particular
expertise is able to evaluate land use
decisions it allows somebody that would
like to appeal a ruling of a local board
can go to the housing appeals board now
with this amendment language or choose
to go to the land you stock it this adds
an extra judge and that was the concern
last year in judiciary when we retained
the bill was we didn't have the
resources to at that time is the second
year to appoint a new judge now we can
do that I think it gives them a great
opportunity to pick where you'd like to
appeal it there's dockets for a number
of issue areas there's the family court
there's a bunch of different areas I
think by appointing one Justice or one
judge to this particular area
the reason why we need to do this
because there's a housing crisis and
let's allow the courts to evaluate each
and every decision on their own Merit
but allow the judge with that particular
expertise let's do it thank you
are there anyone else comments yes
representative Perez
clarification when was that study done
this past year
um and then another question yes is it
not by understanding please correct me
if I Wrong
um is the new
budget financials is that also putting
forward to add an additional five
justices as well
no no well I'm sorry representative
Smith
first of all we don't know
the answer to that because we don't know
until February 14th what the governor
proposes to put in his budget we do know
that you have to look at the differences
between the Circuit Court which is very
short and the Superior Court which is
also short what this language in this
field does is addressed only the
superior court and says that there has
to be an additional
um an additional judge added to the
roster that had been 21 and would go up
to 22. when we vote on this bill it will
go to the house and it will then go to
division if it passes
and I have every reason to believe it it
will pass in part because of the
identity of the Prime sponsor
um and we have to take that into account
too
I'm serious I'm serious I mean we you
know that that is a factor it will go to
division one
of finance division one has a lot of
responsibilities including the Judiciary
they can what they will likely do is
hold this bill
until they see what the governor has
proposed in the budget because they will
not I don't believe they will handle
this separately they will want to make
sure that there is an additional
uh Superior Court judge
yes representative Perez
I'm sorry I just so is it my
understanding that
specifically a Justice a judge for this
particular
um need was addressed by this group
minus new people last summer and was
voted
down it correct me if I'm wrong
was voted not to have or went down
fourteen to five is that what I'm
understanding from the information from
representative Andrus and if I could
follow up on that you're you're
absolutely right
um but circumstances change
last time if I remember correctly there
was no provision that said
if this and I'm sure representative
Alexander will correct me if I'm wrong
um this there was no language that said
there had to be an additional judge the
concern of the Judiciary Committee in
the previous term and I believe the
concern is Judiciary Committee today is
that there are not enough judges to
handle uh the caseload in the superior
and circuit courts
um in a manner that is timely and we all
know that Justice delayed is Justice
denied a key difference in this bill is
not only that there would be someone who
had specific knowledge but that in order
for this bill to be passed there would
have to be an additional judge added so
that the um the caseload
responsibilities would would switch
and so that was I think a a key
difference and uh because this is a
budget year
whereas 2020 uh two was not a budget
year there was no way to be able to add
an additional adjuster to the superior
Corps and now the timing is that we can
we have the possibility of adding
um a Justice where we didn't have last
year representative Perez
I'm sorry the learning process
did I not also hear that a study was
done prior to that decision last fall
about the caseload of justices
yeah
well no no that I think I I can answer
that so you need to I think you need to
understand we're talking about we're
talking about there was a study done not
but it was not just about the superior
court and that study was not was in
process
but the the study itself didn't come out
until
I believe it was
it was the it was like last fun it was
that was after the session I think it
came I think it came out in November or
December of last year
um it was a weighted caseload study
which shows that both the the superior
and the Circuit Court need additional
judgeships anyway and particularly the
sir I mean the situation is particularly
acute in the Circuit Court which is not
what this deals with
um I believe
um and
you know you got this was based upon a
discussion I had with Chief Justice
McDonald a while ago so things his
thinking on this may have changed but I
believe there was going to be a request
in the budget
for the Circuit Court to increase the
Circuit Court judgeships by seven I
believe
um because there there's a weighted case
study which is pretty complicated but it
kind of explains how many judges are
needed in the bottom line and that was
what was was shown to be needed
um in the in the circuit court now
with regard to as as I think
representative Smith alluded to but with
regard to I think we should all
understand it's particularly the people
who are new
if we pass this bill it goes to finance
Finance
they're under no obligation to to pass
it just because we did and they will
consider the bigger picture and they
might you know they not only the
judicial branch but the whole budget
they they're going to have to figure out
what
priorities for the whole budget so they
you know hopefully I guess I'm hopeful
that they will agree with us if we pass
this but it's you know it'll be up to
them to make another serious look at
this in terms of the overall Financial
picture of the judicial branch and the
and the the state as a whole
um then they'll make their
recommendation and then eventually it
will come back to the whole house to be
voting on the budget
yeah I've just had one more Point
although nobody follows this the reality
is that this is a policy committee and
we are looking at the policy does it
make sense to take uh cases related to
land use and concentrate them it is not
our uh responsibility
we don't have to deal
with whether or not there is enough
money for this we are establishing the
policy it then goes to finance and the
finance committee will tell you they
don't do anything about policy all they
do is the money and if you believe that
I have a bridge to sell you thank you so
you know just just one final point I
would make on this uh um I think it's
really important to understand
that
this bill
just like the housing appeals board Bill
and that bill that housing appeals board
has been in effect for for several years
now it makes no substantive changes to
the law of land use the law doesn't
change at all by this bill or by the
housing appeals board Bill the
substantive law of where you can build
what you can build how much what what
kind of a setback you have to have how
many units you can have all that
neither the housing appeals board nor
this bill makes any change to that so
that you know I I the the comment I made
before I think really is important is
it this bill says it's a good idea to
have a judge that's going to decide
those things be a judge who has some
knowledge in that area as opposed to
just you know you pick a judge out of
the out of the rotation so to speak who
may have some knowledge we have I'm not
saying that no Superior Court judges
have knowledge in this area they do them
now and so you know they have some
knowledge but uh most of them probably
are not expertise I don't have any
expertise in this particular area
this says we would have a judge that
does have that expertisement yes
representative Oregon um but also isn't
part of the rationale that this speeds
up these cases so oh exactly yeah see
you know like whether this development
proposal is going to fly or not uh
sooner that no that's yeah absolutely
not necessarily soon but sooner it's
right an excellent point other yes
representative kuta
I have the utmost respect for for our
chairman
um but I also deeply value the opinions
of of my constituents and the only
constituents I've heard from had a lot
of concerns about this and so that's the
reason for my vote and uh just wanted to
state that
uh yes representative Perez I apologize
but
there are 21 Superior Court Justices now
correct how long have do you know how
long that's been the established number
roughly it's been that way for a uh you
know it's when I first when I first went
on the court and in 1992 there were 29 I
was I became number 29. and that was but
then we had we there was no Family
Division then we handled the Superior
Court handle family cases then when the
Family Division was established the
number of Superior Court judges went
down significantly and it has it has
sort of come up
rather slowly since then so it's back to
now 21.
representative Tripp
thank you
you know uh it seems that a lot of
people on this committee seem to think
that uh
the uh
land use
docket is only going to overturn the uh
the the local land use boards decisions
you know I don't think that's entirely
correct I think that you probably find
that a lot of the land use the local
land use boards decisions are upheld you
know and uh the uh the local land use
boards are interested in moving things
along too so
that's why I believe this is a good bill
and I'll support it
any other comments all right are we
ready for a vote all right then um on
the main Bill uh we're having voted on
the amendment on HB 347 OTP the motion
view on the floor is otpa and I would
ask the clerk to please call the roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews no prep
testerman no
rep Stapleton yes
prep trip yes rep Grayson yes
clerk who tab no rep Perez
no
rep Smith yes
reporgan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep Eaton
yes
rep page
rep Brennan yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza
yes rep Manos yes repturer yes
chairman Lynn yes
the motion passes 16 to 4. all right and
it'll go on the regular calendar
turn to uh
HB 340 uh FN relative to the transfer of
residential property and I recognize
representative Wallace for a motion
I would move House Bill 340 FN in
expedient to legislate
is there a second
I second all right and representative
Wallace would you uh like to speak to
your motion
um pretty simple uh this is going to add
a lot of Regulation to uh Real Estate
Investors and whatnot
um and require a lot of paperwork for
transfer Real Estate to a
um other than a natural person and uh
that's been
you know a lot of business models or
whatnot uh people hold their real estate
and llc's or trusts this is going to
complicate things and uh just not what
we need to do at this point in time
right
anyone else wish to speak uh I'm sorry
representative did you have your hand oh
I'm sorry okay anyone else uh wish to
speak to HB 340.
all right are we ready for a vote
all right
um then I on hb340 the motion uh before
us is an experience to legislate and I
would ask the clerk police to call the
roll
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes reptrip
yes rep Grayson yes Claire kutab yes rep
Perez
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yeah
rep page
rep Brennan yes rep Divine yes rep lonza
yes rep Manos yes
ripped her yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 20-0
all right and um yeah that can go on
consent all right
um then um
379.
um
relative requiring that attorneys be
appointed to represented indigen
sentence during uh residential eviction
proceedings and making an appropriation
therefore uh Mr chair yes do I would
like to make a motion that uh House Bill
379 FN
ought to pass with Amendment 0219h
all right
um is there a second I second it
all right second Dubai I'm sorry who
second the second advice representative
all right uh representative reason do
you wish to uh speak to your motion
thank you Mr chair uh
in all of the discussions and all of the
landlord tenant bills that we have heard
so far the biggest uh issue has been
really in Communications
and this bill uh in particular in its
original form had way too many things to
to that I could not agree to however
uh an amendment this is what this
amendment does is just simply put in the
eviction notice
that the tenant may contact the New
Hampshire legal assistance for Council
that they may be may be eligible for uh
for legal counsel through the New
Hampshire uh legal assistance uh there's
no uh and then of course a statement
that says by calling whatever the phone
number happens to be it would be similar
to uh if you're addicted to gambling you
know all you hear all the disclaimers uh
for the lottery and stuff like that if
you're addicted to gambling call 1-800
I'm addicted or whatever the number
happens to be or akin to the suicide
hotline on the back of a student ID card
things along those lines so it's just
informing the tenant that they may be
eligible for legal assistance
you know uh you know uh representative
greeson I you know I I my only concern I
thought that what what when when we had
talked about this um
that that
um you had that that the that the
amendment said something about the
eviction notice you'll clearly state
that the tenant may be entitled I'm
sorry uh
yeah may be entitled to New Hampshire
legal assistance I guess I'm what I'm
concerned about is it doesn't quite say
that it sort of says may contact New
Hampshire legal assistance and I my only
question is have we
is this in any way
you know sending an un sort of an unfair
signal to a prospective tenant that they
have a some kind of a right to counsel
I'm not because I assume none of us I I
assume you did not mean to say that they
have a right to happen no they they this
is not this is not conveying a
particular right to council but that
they may contact uh New Hampshire legal
assistance if they if they're eligible
if they're qualified I don't know what
the requirements are I don't know who
can and cannot use it what the you know
what any Financial requirements or
anything along those lines it's just
merely saying that they may contact them
after that that's the only obligation is
just the statement in the eviction
notice and if the tenant then decides to
call that they may call
Dr representative Alexander what's uh
I'm wondering if you have any
since you are uh on this housing
community if you have any view on this
well I would also refer to my friend
representative Delorenzo but um I
I think this bill was um a mess to begin
with but I think that this is a simple I
think this is a simple Amendment
um
that I think is a very very very very
very very small bite of the Apple
so let me just ask it's so
um my unders I'm sorry representative
Lorenzo yeah thank you Mr chair
um I think the purpose of the um
amendment is is great
um so I think of it as sort of like a
public service announcement but I I
would like to see that language
tightened up a little bit
I could take out the word guidance okay
Mr chair are we allowed to hold off on
this and maybe pardon are we allowed to
hold off on this this is not an early
built grid this is not uh well no it is
an early Bill I'm sorry it is an early
Bill 379 is an early bill
um so let me just say this I guess what
I would say is yes representative Smith
Mr chair isn't it an early bill because
of the original language in the bill and
all of that line was relating to
um Finance has been removed
um
if the um
so if
yeah you know my only concern would be
suppose if we let's suppose that we put
it off and we and and some at the end we
we didn't adopt this amendment then that
would leave the original bill
which does have that time limitation
that's that's my concern
um
I think it's legitimate concern
I don't think there's any possibility
that the original bill would pass I well
you know what let me ask let me you know
let me just ask this this question
maybe I'm you know maybe this is this is
the lawyer being overly picky about some
language Let me just ask you this I
huh
I'm I understand representative greeson
um to say that it that this language is
not in any way intended to suggest that
that uh uh tenant facing eviction has
some right to an attorney from Legal
Assistance or otherwise uh or or or even
eligibility they may be eligible they
may not
um
I can accept that understanding and if I
guess what I would say is if does
everyone else in the on the committee
agree that this is not in any way
intended to create some right to an
attorney uh that doesn't already exist
um Mr chair
um I agree that it does not create a
right but I'm also thinking of the
calendar we have already scheduled
um
uh an executive session for next
Wednesday it today is Wednesday isn't it
all day it's before noon we can add to
next Wednesdays
um
uh executive session if you really feel
that you want another amendment we could
add it to next Wednesday's schedule take
it up first thing
all right
um and I think that would that might I
don't think it's necessary
um and I think you might want to
remember that this is the legislative
branch not the judicial branch but um if
if for some reason you have a problem I
just don't see why we can't go at go
ahead with this all right representative
when I did my clerk training it was
mentioned that during situations like
this if somebody's willing to run down
to OLS sometimes they can fix this right
up immediately and give us an amendment
and then we could vote on it so maybe
perhaps we could
you know recess this for a few minutes
and and maybe rep reads since she's here
might be willing to run on down for us
that
that sounds that sounds like a very good
idea excellent I I think if that's
possible and totally okay but I also
don't think it's needed because eviction
notices don't appear in the RSA as is
it's always left to the courts to
determine how they put it on the
eviction notice so all this is I think
all this we need to adopt the amendment
but once the amendment's adopted we
leave it to the courts to to make that
decision on what goes on the eviction
notice anyways and that's typically been
the procedure for all of this stuff no I
mean well that's true but I guess my
concern is that this this statute will
be in the law I mean it will that it
will be on the books so yes
representative Warren um thank you I
I I think I think even if we pass
something like this that wouldn't have
been a uh early bill
if we passed it originally I think we
now still have to send it to finance I
speak from uh a personal experience I
had of course that was 2020 during the
pandemic hit during the middle of the
process so everything was a little bit
topsy-turvy but I had a education that
would have cost a significant amount of
money hence was an early Bill and would
have gone to finance but they turned
into a study committee but it still uh
got hurt by Finance although I guess the
finance chair could have waived the
reference and then just sent it straight
on to the
body on the other side of the wall we're
not allowed to talk about but um I think
we still have I think regardless of
whether or not there's a fiscal impact
we still have to like meet the deadline
for the early Bill and it still at least
might have to go to finance thanks if I
could just add one more thing Mr chair
if we could accept this maybe I'm just
trying to keep
adopt the kiss principle which my
children keep on trying you know kept on
trying to tell me to do I never agreed
but
um in this case
we know that the bill would appear has
to go to finance and
Finance might refuse it which would be
great it would then go to the Senate and
if we need to fine-tune something we can
fine tune it in the Senate Mr
representative breeson could go to the
Senate and say you might want to clarify
this this language so so
um
I would urge us to accept this amendment
if it passes and accept the bill keep it
on the schedule that it's on perhaps
suggest to a representative will that he
really doesn't want this bill but if he
does he'll take it and then eventually
it would end up in the Senate and so
there are lots of opportunities
um
uh to fine tune it and there's even one
more and that is that the committee
could suggest a floor Amendment
um
uh if we feel that we want to between
now and when it gets to the floor if we
want to tighten the language so I would
urge us to go ahead now get it off our
books we have so many other bills that
we're dealing with and we have lots of
opportunities we have the finance
committee now first we have the floor
Amendment we have a finance committee
and we have the Senate if we need to
fine tune it anymore
may I yes representative puta in light
of the fact that we still have two more
bills I'm wondering if we could just
hold off on this for a few minutes and
see if if if they could I do agree it is
a bit ambiguous and I and I know other
committees also have a large number of
bills and so I don't want it to get
kicked back just because of that if we
could just see if it might be possible
to change it right now and if it's not
then perhaps consider rep Smith's idea
so let me just ask let me I think that
that makes sense to me let me just ask
you this here's what I've what I suggest
um in in some quick wordsmithing but I
think it accomplishes what at least
would satisfy me suppose we change the
language starting on line 10 of the
amendment so that it would read
the eviction notice shall clearly state
that an Indigent tenet may be eligible
for assistance from New Hampshire legal
assistance uh for uh
you can take you take out the word uh
maybe maybe eligible for assistance from
New Hampshire legal assistance
um
uh for the eviction proceeding and
include instructions on
uh the process for obtaining uh such
assistance
or maybe it may be eligible for
assistance from New Hampshire legal
assistance
um
maybe eligible foreign
suggests that
um we
um put this bill aside at the moment we
asked someone in the room who might be
willing to run quickly down to OLS with
an amendment that would come in under
whose name it can't come in in her name
it has to come under Alexander's name
and stand there until they actually do
it and bring it back to us do you need
me to send an email to OLS
I'll do that I'll be like do whatever
representative Reed says and then we can
vote and we can then have two choices
okay
oh yeah we need to have some boilerplate
that's just doing two movies
convey any
um it can be a Judiciary Community
Amendment but if they need a name use
Alexander nice so yes
hang on hang on wait a minute don't go
yet yeah
did we take out Part B
of establishing a non-lapsing
my other question is during
um Judiciary government said it needed
structure but the other thing we
mentioned during testimony was putting
in that they had to do mediation first
we talked about that but we've kind of
we've tried to kind of let that go if
that's any concern
I think that wasn't set up for all the
counties yet Unfortunately they were
trying to expand that yeah thank you all
right so representative Reed uh hang on
one second here I I I'm sorry I'm gonna
give I'm gonna give you this so let me
let me start again tell me if everyone
is all right with this
the eviction notice shall clearly state
that an Indigent tenant comma although
having no right to counsel comma may be
eligible for legal assistance from New
Hampshire legal assistance for the
eviction and proceeding and include
instructions on the process for
obtaining uh such assistance everybody
representation
to assistance so you don't have
assistance twice
is that oh four shoes for sure for such
representation yes that's fine
all right so is uh hang on I'm gonna
give you this so you can uh
can you leave my chicken scratch all
right
although having no right to counsel may
be eligible for representation
assistance from New Hampshire legal
assistance foreign
I was just gonna say that I'm hearing it
verbally it strikes me as conveying to a
tenant an Indigent tenant you have no
right but you may be eligible I would
rather see it the um although having no
right left out and then a final
concluding sentence this does not
establish a right no guaranteed right
you know what this I've no I I see your
point and I might I might even agree
with you but we're rather than rather
than sort of leave representative Reed
dangling uh the more I think about this
the more I'm thinking that
representative Smith's suggestion that
we just put this off uh deal with its
first thing on on uh next week as the
first item for our agenda for next week
will it seems like everybody's sort of
on board with the idea that we're gonna
we just need to Wordsmith it but
everybody's in agreement that we should
do it is that is that sort of right yes
representative Stapleton I'm not
comfortable with has no right to counsel
I think that sends a wrong message in
Indigent people who don't understand the
law uh might feel affronted by that I
think you can leave that out and still
accomplish it I mean I just wrote down
be eligible for assistance from New
Hampshire legal assistance upon request
doesn't say who makes the request but
makes it simple and direct
ing maybe I can't go with the has no
right to counsel that does that doesn't
sit well
okay
um all right well then we have I think
we I mean my whole my whole purpose
for wanting to change the language was a
concern that somehow this doesn't
you know the the language that's used
doesn't
create an argument in some lawyer's mind
that oh wait a minute they said in here
that you know you're you're uh you have
uh the right you have you have you yeah
you may be eligible but at least that
suggests that they should go there and
if they really are Indigent then they
are eligible that's I that would be my
concern well then you'd have to go to
the analysis the first sentence the bill
provides that an Indigent tenant shall
have the right to counsel
so one place we say it they do and and
then right this second and then we say
no right to counsel I mean both of those
have to be reconciled
right right the event that the the
amendment sort of completely eliminates
379.
so I I don't know I as I've heard the
discussion I think it we would be in
other words
I think it would be better to just uh
hold off until uh next week and we'll
get we'll get some language that that uh
we'll get some input from represent yeah
I'd rather have you not do that and
we'll we'll uh
yeah which and you know you know what
and I don't have a cut can you can you
just make a copy of what I gave you so I
get it back because I don't have another
copy of it
that'd be great
all right
um so I would then propose that we we
hold off on
this bill until
um
three HB 379 until uh next Wednesday and
we'll take it up as the first item
next Wednesday
great thank you
um
could you tell
uh two h
3r and then you know what I think this
it might be a good time to just take a
like a seventh inning stretch does that
sound good for a few minutes
thank you
foreign
we're checking
all right all right I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna call the uh
the committee back to order please
um
so um
all right so we left we left off we're
gonna we're gonna make some quick
changes on two
oh yes we do we need to represent a
testament
and yeah and we need uh representative
yeah where's
foreign
uh okay
oh okay maybe maybe this is oh yes
ah there we go there we go here we go
okay all right
all right
um
I think we've got everybody back so um
I'm gonna call the committee back to
order and and just uh to recap
on on uh HB the 379 FN we're going to
take that up the first thing uh next
Wednesday and uh
uh since we're gonna start at 11 o'clock
on Wednesday we'll presumably we'll have
the language all set to go it will be
you know uh we'll we'll go right through
it very quickly and get the rep and I'll
have a report written by that time so we
can just get it uh uh so it goes to you
know we don't get over the deadline of
getting it in the calendar we'll we'll
make that we'll make that happen all
right so now I I think we're uh done
except for two bills and I'm going to
turn to uh HB 254 and recognize
representative Wallace for a motion
I would move House Bill 254 in Expedia
to legislate is there a second I second
all right representative Wallace do you
wish to speak to uh briefly thank you uh
is this bill addresses local uh boards
um within a town or a particular
District they're by definition they're
close by there really shouldn't be any
need to do this stuff remotely
um
you know people run for the office
knowing there's going to be a bit of a
time commitment a couple of days a week
in town so let's get to the uh town
meeting office and let's get these held
in person uh that's the way it needs to
be done
thank you anyone else wish to be here
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair I I would like to point out
current RSA uh provides for the ability
to attend and vote remotely in special
situations for instance in Goffstown we
had necessary warrant articles that need
to be voted on and we had a selectman
that was traveling for business he was
allowed to vote remotely so he could
have his vote up here on the on the town
warrant
um so there's already RSA that provides
for situations or provides for this
specific situation so this bill is just
not needed
representative page thank you thank you
Mr chair I'll be voting against the
motion for itl um and let folks know
that I would propose an amendment that I
distributed through email and hard copy
to this bipartisan bill that I think
addresses This concerns that were raised
in hearing uh relative to preserving
some of the bodies that already do meet
or have the option to meet remotely
um and and then um
so so that that would be my my position
on this that
um this you know covid allows public
bodies local public bodies to do that
we've clarified the term and the
amendment to exclude town meeting so I
think that I'll be voting against I will
be voting against this and through and
would like the committee to understand
an amendment that I think address the
concerns that we heard
at hearing so thank you very much anyone
else wish to be heard on yes
representative Perez
does this Inc exclude I know it excludes
Town meetings but does it it doesn't
exclude school meetings correct because
we have a town deliberative and a school
deliberative
um
and our form of government is separate
town from school so therefore I feel
concerns that school isn't included in
this
representative Smith you I believe you
was this I don't want to respond to
General Perez's question oh
representative page uh if somebody yeah
somebody else have a
oh
representative testerman I'm sorry did
you have some
thank you uh I know that we've become
quite enamored with uh remote meetings
uh at almost every level
uh I
almost 100 percent don't participate in
them because I believe the kind of
government that we have here in New
England had a requirement to get
everybody in attendance that wanted to
participate
was the best way to do it and I think
now that we were trying just to pick off
all these various things onesie twosy
and and I'm against it
thank you representative
um representative Smith did you wish to
speak um yes thank you um
I hear what representative
testerman says and
um
and at some levels I'm quite sympathetic
to that I live in an sb2 town which no
longer has Town meetings
and I find it very sad uh because very
few people show up at the meeting to
hear what's you know to discuss possible
amendments or whatever they show up only
to vote and they don't necessarily know
what they're voting on I think it's
important for people to participate
physically and
um
and and as I say missed the town meeting
approach
however
um
with all the negatives that came from
covid
we have found
in many Arenas that a lot more people
pay attention
if they can be sitting at home and
watching
um and uh we see that here in the
legislature when you look at how many
people sign up to say they're supporting
or opposing a particular bill and the
more people who do that the better in
this case we're not just talking about
the The Observers so to speak we're
talking about the decision makers
and I think it's good to have people in
the room and to be able to see
how they're reacting and to be able to
respond quickly
but I also think that what this bill
does is look at situations
where we have been able to involve more
people in the decision-making process by
having them participate remotely
and it is not mandatory the uh as I
understand it and perhaps I'm wrong it
is still up to the local jurisdiction to
decide how they want to handle it and
some local jurisdictions will say no but
the ones that want to say yes I think
um deserve the right to do that and so
um uh while I would like to have
everybody participate in person I am
going to be supporting uh house bill
254.
anyone else wish to be representative
mannox thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to address
um representative Perez's concern by
pointing out that under the amendment
specifically school meetings and town
meetings are excluded or Exempted and so
I think this the amendment addresses her
specific concern all right
representative Perez I'm sorry I have
one more concern
um
if I call up call in on the phone to be
part of a meeting how do you know it's
me
how do you know it's me
um
how do I know that
representative well couldn't be you but
who's your man and they know
representative Divine wasn't calling in
in my town or someplace on a meeting
to represent me I think if they had to
be seeing somebody is entirely different
than hearing from somebody I was
involved in a long case with speaking to
a judge in Arizona and lawyers and
I had no idea who they were at all I
think I think it opens Pandora's Box so
all right uh representative Stapleton
if as I mentioned before that in the
Sullivan County delegation we have uh
sometimes one or two people who on
travel or illness can't make the meeting
but we want their valued input and so we
have a screen and for the most part
there's visibility there as well as
audio for the person speaking if they
don't have the camera capability then we
have the voice which we recognize and or
is uh validated that that's the right
number the right person connected to it
uh you know by the
by the chair
um
my attitude is the bill is unnecessary
because if it's not already prohibited
by law and not illegal
we already have the right and leaving it
up to the discretion of the local
instrumentality or authority
makes sense under our Live Free or Die
concept anyone else wish to speak uh
representative Oregon
um another
Factor Why the remote meetings um
profusials that in many communities the
school is the only facility that's
suitable for holding a public meeting
and even when it's not you know you have
the school board would prefer to meet
like in Durham we do a very nice Town
Hall but the school board prefers to
meet at the school and that creates
certain issues uh well there's federal
gun law and then there's certain members
Community who wish to participate in the
meeting who either cannot well in some
cases they don't feel they can ever take
their gun off but at least they
certainly would prefer uh not to take it
off so they can participate at home
where you know you say your own gun laws
and controversy when there's a
respiratory disease
well there's some people who don't want
to go anywhere without the mask is
afraid of catching diseases others who
feel they cannot wear the mask for
health reasons of their own so those are
and I'm sure we'll have more respiratory
uh epidemics the covet one wasn't the
last one so those are two situations
where the remote meetings are very very
handy because it uh
it so you don't have to worry about
issues with people who cannot go to
these specific uh venue where the
meeting is being held and of course you
have the uh people are disabled who
can't travel easily so
that's like another good thing about uh
expanding these remote meetings and
which
we're much better which at least in my
community were attempted uh much better
it'll attended as well or many cases
better than the uh traditional in-person
meetings all right anyone else wish to
speak on uh HB 254 representative
Andrews thank you Mr chairman
I am totally against remote meetings
when I became a legislator two years ago
it was in covert and everything was
remote and the state the county the
schools
I attended so many meetings there were
inaudible you have no idea what was
going on
one particular situation there's
actually two of them I was supposed to
be participating in the meeting
there was no way it was Audible and I
just left it might not have been the
right thing to do I think like equipment
what are we going to demand that each
place has for equipment I mean it
depends on how good you can project what
you're doing if you don't have
appropriate equipment
I just feel is too easy to set home and
do a remote
and there are many people
that don't even have access to computers
or anything like that and might want to
do something in person
I just feel we're also opening up a
candle rooms a Pandora's Box whatever
you want to call it
and there's going to be a lot of issues
that we
cannot take care of thank you
representative Manos I just wanted to
also add that under the a bill a quorum
of at least a third of the total
membership of the public body would have
to be present at the physical location
of the meeting and so there is a
physical presence it's not that and that
is required and so there is a physical
presence and it's not that everyone
would be participating by electronic
means
so I think
um given that the impractic the
impracticalness of of um
everyone attending I think that this is
a good and reasonable solution to
um to the problem
all right anyone else who should be
heard representative Gleason thank you
Mr chair
I think we are
conflating a couple of different things
first of all
the general public we we broadcast the
meetings to the general public we are
meeting in person but it is being put
out and you can live stream it on
YouTube you can participate you could
sign up and voice your support
um we are not taking any questions from
anybody or comments from anybody via
live stream we don't have a screen up
here where we could see anybody dial in
um
so that is a separate issue the
participation getting people to
participate in these meetings is a whole
lot different than the body that is
meeting because they are the ones who
have to hold the meeting
if the current bill allows only one
third of the members to be present to
have a quorum
that means in a school board where
there's only three members one person
draws the Short Straw to go in and turn
all the equipment on and have a meeting
in person by him or herself while the
other two can stay home and warm by the
fire
I don't know how you can honestly
transact the business at hand when only
one third of its of its me of its
members
is comprises a quorum
anyone else wish to speak to uh HB 254
yes representative Brennan thank you am
I understanding correctly that we are
still discussing the original Bill and
not the amended bill
the I've uh yeah there's been no there's
been no more yeah the emotion on the
floor is to itl the original bill
there's been no amendment has been
presented on the floor because we
haven't because we're dealing with the
itl motion
if I may yes um
I'm looking at the amended version and
I'm not quite sure exactly what has
changed in the amended version but I
would like to point out that
what I'm reading is that this is an
enabling bill that would allow governing
bodies to make the decision if they
would allow
for this remote participation from a
member of the governing body to
participate in their meetings this is
not a mandatory remote meeting bill this
is allowing it says may allow
additionally a concern that was heard
was that members would not be able to
see but it says explicitly here that
each member participating electronically
or otherwise shall be able to
contemporaneously and throughout the
meeting see and hear and be seen and
heard by other members of the public
body attending the meeting
am I understanding it correctly that
every member of the governing body would
need to be seen and heard whether they
are present in the meeting a space or
on the electronic communication
yes representative cuta in the original
bill it doesn't say that it says or so
the bill that we're talking about now
does not say that
thank you for that clarification
representative Horgan did you wish to
say something
well yes one of I believe this
the camera is disability one of the
others where the right to know spokesman
made a big point of saying we have to be
able to read the members body language
and I'm not sure I mean obviously it's
part of how we're communicating but
it seems to me we're I'm really
responsible for our words and the body
language is often can be often be
misconstrued I remember many years ago
my first term are
the chair of this committee
happen to have a physical disability so
sometimes he Twitches or you
involuntarily appeared to be laughing
even though he was
um
and even though it's in fact a very
respectful uh respectful person and his
words were always carefully slogan so
like some people who didn't like what
the committee doing were accusing him of
laughing at them on the stand when the
fact that was uh well he does have
several right sense of humor but that
was absolutely not what's happening so
um
so I think I don't know I think it's
something I think so I think I'm not
so I think to some extent uh
some some extent they were asking they
were demanding it so they can like uh
read something into people's body
language which may or may not have been
there and although we have a zoom
meeting or whatever you you can see
people in their little frame so
sometimes you can sort of read more of
their expressions than you can in person
so I think
um I don't know I'm kind of
now I've lost it I think it may have
drifted off topic here but but you know
we are primarily responsible for our
words not for our body language and also
um this is also the purpose of any
meeting is primarily so the members of
the body can discuss the issue amongst
themselves and then when need be
have members of public or other outside
members with the member purpose of the
meeting is primarily for discussion
amongst the members of the body rather
than uh just to allow themselves to be
scrutinized and confronted by
you know whoever
by like whoever random people like are
taking an interest in the committee for
whatever reason so thanks all right
anyone else wish to speak on uh HP 254.
all right so the motion on the floor is
I is itl on uh House Bill 254. are we
ready for the question
all right
um I would ask the clerk to please call
the roll uh itl on 254. Vice chairman
Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep Grayson
yes
clerk who tab yes rep Perez
rep Smith
reporgan no
rep Delorenzo no
rep Eaton yes
reppage no
rep Brennan no
rep Divine yes
replanza yes
rope Manos
no
ripped her no
the motion oh sorry chairman Lynn yes
the motion passes 13 to 7.
all right
um
okay
um hang on just one second
all right all right
uh that will go on the regular uh
calendar
um
regular let me just all right I'm gonna
now uh turn
to HB 308 and I would recognize myself
since I did the amendment for an
amendment
um which is amendment uh
I'm sorry I moved uh ought to pass on uh
3 40 and I offer amendments I'm sorry
three motion
ought to pass on 308 and
um is there a second
second all right and I offer now
Amendment
240h to 308 and is there a second on
that
second
and if I may speak to the motion
um
this motion this this amendment
is
designed to
allow for remote meetings by State uh
boards it's specifically excludes the
gov the general court or either house
thereof or any Committee of either house
and it also specifically excludes the
governor and Council it applies to
however All State agencies boards
committees councils advisory committees
and the like and I took that language
out of
other
sections of the right to know law uh the
composition of which is permitted by law
or regulation to be drawn from
individuals who may reside throughout
the state of New Hampshire so this would
apply for example to
The Advisory representative page you
mentioned uh an advisory commission uh
as it was a disabilities
two yeah one is the developmental
Services quality Council which is
established under RSA and then there's a
special education advisory Council if I
have that right that Sac I think right
so it might I mean it wouldn't it would
cover those kind of state you know
Statewide advisory councils yeah thank
you it's um and it's specifically uh
permits uh remote meetings it requires
um at least one third of the total
membership to be present and you'll
you'll notice I did make a slight change
in this language from what was used in
some of the other in for example the 254
and I think even the original version of
I think I think it would be problematic
to say in the in the thing about
one-third I think it would be
problematic to say
it you have to have a quorum or
one-third whichever is less
and then say later that
um a member participating remotely uh it
qualifies for the Quorum because if you
kept it if you worded it the way it was
originally worded at least that argument
could be made that well wait a minute uh
all you have to have present is a cool
all you have to have present is a quorum
we've defined Quorum later on to be a
person who's remote and so at least
there would be an argument at least
there would be a conflict so I changed
it to say at least one-third that just
took that out
um I think that
um
this amendment makes makes sense it I
understand that there are concerns about
having remote meetings at all
um and I
in many ways I'm sympathetic to that on
the other hand I think that uh
representative Upham Nutter uh pointed
out that there are a number of if she
was talking about the rare disease I
think advisory Council that there are a
number of these uh committees
um where they draw it's a Statewide
committee they draw people from around
the state so the travel issue is a lot
more uh uh of a real issue than it would
be in terms of local uh or County uh uh
boards or commissions
um
and so I think that
uh this makes sense uh to do this uh and
I hope uh I hope that
um we'll get a bipartisan vote to
support this because I do I do think
um it makes sense and I and although I
appreciate uh
um uh representative up uh uh Nutter
upham's uh concerned in particular about
the disabilities uh uh I mean I'm sorry
the rare disease uh advisory Council I I
I don't think and I hope that most of
the majority of you will agree that it
doesn't make sense to pick out one
particular board
um it makes more sense to just have a
kind of a general generally applicable
uh
uh proficient so with that I hope you
will support uh this amendment
representative uh Oregon
um thank you I
happen to belong to a well actually it's
a
Vital Records privacy board which is um
a joint under the Aegis of uh Health and
Human Services and the Secretary of
State's office and um
they and they read in this they actually
meet in the same facility where I
believe the rare disease board would
meet if it had ever had an in-person
meeting in the last couple of years and
that's in the secure area of uh well the
hhs's office on offices on on Hazen
drive so it's in the small
conference room that has fairly robust
uh
teleconferencing facilities and they
often have a variety of meetings there
many of which are confidential so it
isn't really practical to have a large
group of the public uh in that small
conference room although they do have a
Auditorium in other spaces they could
use if for some reason
a large number of uh
people from the general public showed up
usually uh usually nobody shows up in
the case of my board I'm not even
I think maybe they're doing a little bit
of security by security I'm not even
sure exactly where you would go to find
out that it exists but um
so as a as a practical matter the rare
disease conference is one of a number of
bodies some of which are in groups some
of which are covered by you know this
law some of which are you know just ad
hoc groups in HHS who really it isn't
necessarily practice with them to meet
in the auditorium except in rare rare
occasions and so it's more practical for
them to meet you know securely through
their well-established teleconferencing
facilities which work pretty well I've
participated in board meetings both in
person and uh and uh and and remotely
and their experience has been good
either way so all right that's just my
my two cents on it and that was I've
explained what the original impetus for
the bill was so and it um it applies not
just to that committee but to a number
of other committees so I think they
should be they should be allowed to uh
meet meet remotely in most cases thanks
anyone else wish to speak on this
amendment to uh House Bill 308
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair
um
the ability to have
a remote person constitute help
constitute Quorum is really helpful and
avoids the inefficiency of not being
able to do business in a meeting for
those that have physically gathered
and you know we're getting into
situations illness travel a disability
weather
and so I think this is an important
provision and and we we protect it by
having a roll call vote in the case of
having a remote person attending so I'm
in favor of it right anyone else wish to
uh speak on the amendment to HB 308
um so I uh this is an amendment we can
vote by a Voice vote or unless somebody
wants to have a roll call
yes all right there's been a request for
a role yeah I'm sorry so we'll have a
roll call vote then on the amendment uh
representative Andrews do you
I didn't mean to cut you off thank you
Mr chair
again I'm going to vote against this I
do not believe in remote meetings I
understand what everybody says I'm not
had it by any means
but when you take an office or you go on
a committee
you know right then and there you need
to show up and if you don't show up or
do you feel that you're not going to you
should not
say yes to being on a committee or
anything I mean that's all I've got to
say I just don't believe in the remote I
think we this ever got passed I think
it's just going to be Mayhem with all
the boards and Committees of a lot of
them and not anybody's going to know
what's going on thank you all right
anyone else wish to speak on the
amendment to HB 308
all right uh then we're ready for the
question and I would ask the clerk to
please call the roll on amendment
240h to house bill 308.
chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander
rep Andrews no
rep testerman no rep Stapleton yes
reptrip yes
rep Grayson no
clerk who tab yes rep Perez
rep Smith
reporigan yes rep Delorenzo yes
rep Eaton yes
rep page yes
rep Brennan yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza
yes rep Vanos yes repturer yes chairman
Lynn yes
motion passes 15 to 5.
uh
all right so you know what I think I
think we're done but I just wanna we
have to vote on the otpa now oh oh I'm
sorry okay yes all right yeah all right
so
um anyone want to speak any further on
the motion now to uh uh of otpa
yes representative Wallace let's move
the question all right I'll second that
anyone else wish to speak on
on that all right so now that's their uh
clerk to please call the roll on the
main motion of otpa House Bill 308 as
amended
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
no rep Andrews no rep testerman no rep
Stapleton yes reptrip yes
rep Grayson no
clerk who tab yes rep Perez
rep Smith
rep Horrigan yes rep Delorenzo yes rep
Eaton yes rep page yes
rep Brennan yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza
yes rep Manos yes repterra yes
chairman Lynn yes
the motion passes 15 to 5.
okay Al
um
I think now we are done except for two
things um on uh 254
um
uh
representative uh Wallace can I ask you
to write the report on for the for the
majority report and uh representative
Smith is there someone who will write
The Minority Report
minority okay all right uh well let's
see yeah and yeah
hang on one second
all right and on um 308
um
I guess uh
representative Smith has has rightly
pointed out that I've created a lot of
work for myself by writing firefighting
amendments and stuff like that but since
I wrote the amendment I'll write the uh
majority report on 308 will there be a
Minority Report
all right
so I will write the majority and
representative Andrus will write the
minority
all right
see we're letting you make these motions
we know you're going to train yourself
out of it pretty soon right right right
right uh
Andrews
all right so um
what I'd uh
what I'd like is to say still remember
these reports don't have to be long they
don't have to be you know
uh very detailed but I I would like to
ask to have the reports in again by the
close of business tomorrow
um so we can get and I'm making I'm
imposing the deadline probably more but
I'm more on myself than on other people
but I think it's important that we get
this in uh so we can get it to the
clerk's office
um with that
um
yes representative Perez
the whole house is I mean the house but
no we are not we are not meeting
tomorrow we are not meeting tomorrow and
you know what the other thing I would
say um um as we recess
um uh uh our representative uh Smith has
asked if this room can be used for a
call for a democratic caucus and I said
yes so we need to when we clear out we
need to clear out so that they so that
they have they can take the room for
their caucus so with that
um thank you all and uh I'll see you
tomorrow
thanks to our substitutes for for being
here for sure
thank you
the the Democrats
the Democrats on the committee can we'll
have a lunch break and we'll reconvene
here at one o'clock
this